we now return to the 147th annual NRA
Image Awards
[Music]
accuracy dependability stopping power
these are all attributes we look for in
the perfect gun
you said it these are all an apt
description of the nominees for gun of
the year
shotgun
fifteen the winner is
these are so hard out I bet you wish you
had a gun right now I do and the winner
is
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the 59th nomination and 59 3 m4
ar-15 Wow you think I get used to this
by now where do I begin so many people
to think first it's just an honor to be
mentioned in this category we've had
such a good year this year and every
year I guess I share this award with all
the nominees secondly I have to think
the love of my life
Republican senator from Arizona Dale
Donnelly your support for me has never
wavered I truly don't know how you do it
sometimes it doesn't make sense you know
there are some guns out there who are
worried that you're unnecessary when I
was a young gun they told me I wasn't
necessary but did I stay home no I went
to schools movie theaters back-to-school
churches in all the schools no one can
pull the trigger by themselves but
together we can god Bless America the
only place where this is possible thank
you
[Music]
when we come back Ted Nugent kills the
last white rhino and another performance
by thoughts and prayers at the 147th
annual NRA Image Awards
you